[Music]
welcome to the IBM BPM eight five seven
zero demonstration on theme support I
have open in front of me a client-side
human servers called travel requests
let's say that this client-side human
service along with several others have
been deployed in production for a
certain amount of time our organization
would like to upgrade the look and feel
of all the UIs within this process app
in the past this would have been
accomplished by changing the CSS that is
attached to the various coach views and
redeploying a new snapshot of the
process app in eight five seven a new
mechanism called theme support allows a
simple centralized mechanism to update
the UI s across the process up this
mechanism also allows the look and feel
to be updated after a process app has
been deployed without the need to
republish a new version of the process
app theme support and BPM is based on
less less is an open source CSS pre
compiler it adds the ability to define
variables and use those in your CSS
declarations here is a simple example of
some less code we have BPM button
primary BG defined as a variable what
the value set to it we also have two CSS
rules beneath it my button and my
section header in their definitions we
can see the usage of the variable
browsers do not understand less it is
compiled into CSS beneath we can see the
variable being substituted to create the
standard CSS that we're all used to in
BPM is a new artifact called a theme
which has all the variable declarations
in the system coach views that our theme
enabled have a dynamic style set on them
and this is less code that leverages the
variables defined in the theme there is
one active theme for process a per
toolkit and all coach views within the
scope share that styling back in the
designer we're going to get started by
creating a new team
our new theme can be called dark theme
when the editor opens we're taken to the
design tab design tab shows all the
variables on the left group together and
a preview on the right showing the
result and look and feel the coach views
with the current settings to change an
aspect of the UI I can hover over the
different regions in the preview pane
here we can see that the background
color is BPM body BG for this area
finding that variable on the left I can
click on the color swatch which should
invoke a dialog for me to pick a new
color as soon as I set a new value for
the variable we can see the preview is
updated on the right hand side let's say
we want to change the color for this
primary button the background color is
BPM button primary BG if we find that on
the left side we can see that BPM button
primary BG is referring to another theme
variable called BPM colored primary we
can choose to change the button
background color alone or we can choose
this more general variable which will be
applied to numerous other spots within
the UI here we see that the section
header and the switch have been updated
as well I can continue using this
technique to set other aspects of the UI
for example I might change the text to
be larger here we can see that font size
screaming from BPM font size base
we can also change some of the border
radiuses to soften a look of things I
have adjusted a few more variables to
achieve the look that I'm after before I
close this editor I'm going to go to the
source tab in the source tab we can see
all the variables on the left and on the
right we can see some metadata this is
what contributes the variable to the
design tab it is possible to add new
variables to the theme and use those
variables in your custom coach views you
can also leverage the same metadata to
achieve the easy to use controls for
setting the values such as the color
pickers and font Pickers now that we
have our theme defined we're going to
save the editor and set this theme on
the process app in the process app
settings there's a theme field here here
we will select the dark theme we just
authored and save this editor if we
switch back to the travel request and we
wait a few moments we can see the theme
is applied the CSS generation happens on
the server from the theme artifacts
running the client-side human service we
can see the theme is applied at runtime
as well to complete this demonstration
I'm going to show how to update the
theme on process apps that are already
deployed to a process server this slide
shows what we're going to do we have a
number of process apps that are deployed
to the process server each one depends
on the system toolkit and each one is
using the default BPM theme we're going
to create a new theme toolkit which has
the dark theme inside of it and we're
going to create a new dummy process app
that depends on the theme toolkit we're
going to deploy the dummy process app
and then use the BPM update theme
command to dynamically set the theme on
the running process apps without be
deploying them I am in process
portal where we can see I have the
employee travel process deployed if I
launch an instance of this process I can
see the work item if I accept that work
item we can see the default theme is
applied to the coach let's update this
theme to the dark theme that we just
created in process Center we can see the
dummy process app that I created this
references the toolkit that contains the
dark theme I'm going to install this new
process app onto that process server
I'm logged into the Waze admin console
for the process server on which our
process apps are deployed I'm going to
run the BPM update theme command with
the proper parameters we can see that
the command is successful so let's go
back and rerun our process back in the
same process portal is earlier we'll
relaunch that process claim the work
item we can see that the theme is
updated even though we did not redeploy
a new version of the travel request
process app this concludes the
demonstration on theme support in BPM 85
7-0 themes support provides a simple
centralized mechanism for controlling
the look and feel of all you is within
your BPM process apps thank you
[Music]